كيف يبدو ذلك كيف تعمل
في تلك البيئة حسنًا، الجنوب
كلمة كبيرة وفي الجنوب توجد عدة
مناطق كنا نطلب من GTH أه
الانتقال إلى منطقة ماساسي وهي
المنطقة الأقرب إلى البحر أه وهذا  هو
المكان الذي تم إنشاء المدن العشر الكبرى
أه القتال في
الحنون الجنوبي لا يعني أننا نقاتل
في نفس المنطقة وكما
رأيتم في الثنائي في الأسبوعين الماضيين
القتال جراحي للغاية
فهو بطيء  منهجي جدا
نحاول عدم الوصول إلى أي من
أه السكان غير المقاتلين في
قطاع غزة وأه وأعتقد أه أنه
لا توجد طريقة يمكننا من خلالها القضاء على
حماس دون التعامل مع معظم
قواتها التي كانت كذلك  هربوا إلى
الجنوب الآن مرة أخرى ملاحظة صغيرة
أه السكان غير الأكفاء في
قطاع غزة هو في الحقيقة مصطلح غير موجود
لأن
كل الغزيين صوتوا لحماس
وكما رأينا في 7
أكتوبر معظم السكان  في
قطاع غزة هم حماس، ومع ذلك فإننا
نعاملهم على أنهم غير مقاتلين،
ونعاملهم كمدنيين عاديين ويتم
إعفاؤهم من
القتال